Te presento a la tribu más violenta del mundo,
conocidos como los SENTINELESES.
El año pasado, en 2018, mataron a un misionero
que quería evangelizarles.
La policía de la India todavía no se ha
atrevido a recoger el cuerpo.
Nadie que haya contactado con ellos ha regresado.
Por eso, los sentineleses han permanecido
aislados del mundo durante siglos, en esta
isla remota situada en el océano indico.
Nadie se atreve a visitarles.
A estas alturas, te preguntarás ¿Por qué
te hablamos de esta tribu tan violenta?
Pues muy sencillo: estas islas pertenecen
al archipiélago de ANDAMAN y NICOVAR.
Y en contra de lo que puede parecer, esta
ristra de islas es fundamental para el comercio
internacional.
Básicamente, todos los petroleros que llegan
a China pasan por aquí.
Eso significa que, en cualquier momento, la
India podría bloquear el tráfico y colapsar
toda la economía china en cuestión de meses.
Y, creedme, podría ocurrir.
La India no es, precisamente, un buen amigo
de China.
¿Y qué está haciendo China para evitar
todo esto?
¿Estamos hablando del inicio de una guerra?
Bueno, esperemos que no… La respuesta es
mucho más complicada que todo esto.
Los que seguís VisualPolitik desde hace tiempo
ya os estaréis imaginando de por dónde voy:
exacto, el collar de perlas.
En este vídeo, os contaremos cómo China
y la India se están amenazando mutuamente…
¡Vamos a verlo!
En anteriores episodios de VisualPolitik os
contamos cómo China amenaza al Imperio Americano:
esto es, a los Estados Unidos.
La iniciativa Belt and Road y, sobretodo,
su versión martítima a la que llamamos el
Collar de Perlas son la estrategia china para
neutralizar la influencia estadounidense en
el índico.
Si recordáis, lo llamamos “collar de perlas”
porque cada perla representa un Puerto Chino
que podría convertirse en una base militar.
Pero Estados Unidos no son los únicos que
están preocupados por esta posible expansión
militar.
Ahora vamos a ver cómo la India también
tiene razones para tener miedo.
Pero antes, os estaréis preguntando ¿Dónde
están estas perlas?
Pues… estas perlas están en algunas zonas
como BANGLADESH, SRI LANKA o PAKISTAN.
Y ya sé lo que estáis pensando.
En principio, ninguno de estos proyectos son
militares.
En todos los casos, hablamos de puertos comerciales,
aeropuertos, autopistas… Así que ¿Dónde
está el problema?
Las autopistas son buenas para la economía
¿no?
¡Oh!
¡Vaya!
¿De repente está mal que los chinos quieran
hacer dinero?
¡Por supuesto que no!
Pero ¿De verdad quieren hacer dinero… o
en realidad el interés es otro?
Vamos a poner un ejemplo: el puerto de HAMBANTOTA,
en SRI LANKA.
Sri Lanka es un país que tuvo una guerra
civil hace unos años y que está hecho unos
zorros.
Y el puerto de Hambantota está por ahí,
muerto de risa.
Para que os hagáis una idea, en el año 2017,
sólo 183 barcos pasaron por ahí.
Pues bien, China ha invertido la friolera
de 1000 millones de dólares en este puerto.
Por si fuera poco, han construido toda una
ciudad a su alrededor.
Desde 0 ¿Tiene sentido económico?
Pues… más bien no.
Ahora bien, si lo miramos desde un punto de
vista militar, tener un puerto al ladito de
la India le viene de perlas a China.
Y aquí es donde vienen los miedos ¿Y si
lo que China está intentando es expandirse
militarmente?
Pensadlo bien: por extraño que parezca, China
está en una posición extremadamente débil.
Muchos países pueden bloquear sus rutas comerciales
en cualquier momento.
Y, creedme, tanto China como Japón estarían
encantados de hacerlo.
Es más, si no lo hacen hasta ahora es, en
parte, porque América no quiere.
Pero, vistas el cariño que le tiene Trump
a los chinos, no sería raro que un día cambiaran
las cosas.
En otras palabras, China tiene lo que llamamos
un riesgo existencial.
Y para eso necesitan tener bases militares
fuera del país.
Y aquí es donde vienen los problemas ¿Por
qué un país va a dejar que China construya
sus bases militares en su territorio?
Y lo que es más importante ¿Bastaría con
unas bases militares para que China estuviera
segura?
Por ejemplo… ¿Por qué tener un puesto
en Sri Lanka es tan importante para China?
Hoy, vamos a responder a todas estas preguntas
pero antes, vamos a ver un poco de historia.
DIPLOMACIA SUGAR DADDY
Para los que no lo conozcáis, Sri Lanka es
esa islita que hay al sur de la India.
Tienen alrededor de 21 millones de habitantes
y… si nunca habéis oído hablar de ellos,
no os preocupéis.
Hasta ahora, su importancia política era
0.
Así que os voy a hacer un resumen de lo que
pasa por aquí.
Durante 26 años, Sri Lanka sufrió una guerra
civil con un grupo terrorista: los Tigres
Libertadores del TAMIL EELAM.
Hablamos de un conflicto donde más de 60.000
personas perdieron la vida.
Algunas estimaciones hablan de hasta 100.000
personas.
Como os podéis imaginar, las violaciones
de derechos humanos se dieron en ambos lados
y, durante décadas, el gobierno de Sri Lanka
estuvo aislado de la comunidad internacional.
Eso significa que, el gobierno lo tenía muy
complicado para conseguir armas para luchar
contra los tigres del TAMIL EELAM.
Y, en ese momento, cuando el mundo entero
le daba la espalda a Sri Lanka, sólo había
un país listo para ser su amigo.
O más bien, su sugardaddy.
Sí, amigos de VisualPolitik, hablamos de…
Durante el desfile de la Victoria de Sri Lanka
se reveló la ayuda proporcionada por China
Estas noticias son del año 2009, año en
el que Sri Lanka derrota a los tigres.
La guerra había terminado.
Y en ese momento, el flamante presidente del
país era este señor que veis en la pantalla,
que se llama MAHINDA RAJAPAKSA.
El clásico lider autoritario, corrupto y
hambriento de poder.
Llegó al poder en 2005 y, desde el primer
momento, China le ofreció todo ese armamento
que necesitaba para derrotar a los tigres.
De esta forma, Rajapaksa podría ganar un
montón de credibilidad como el hombre que
terminó con la guerra civil en Sri Lanka.
Pero la historia no termina aqui!
Veréis… en este mundo, no hay nada más
fácil que jugar con el ego de un señor con
ganas de poder.
Y así es como China se convirtió en el sugardaddy
de Rajapaksa.
Por si no lo sabéis, un sugardaddy es un
señor muy rico que se dedica a pagarle un
montón de lujos a una chica para que sea
su novia.
Pues esto es lo que pasó con Sri Lanka.
A ver, Rajapaksa ¿Qué quieres construir
la torre más alta de todo el Sur de Asia?
¿Un pedazo monumento para que todos vean
lo grande que la tienes?
¡Claro que sí, guapetón!
¡Aquí llega China con la tarjeta de crédito!
¿Qué dices, Rajapaksa?
¿Qué ahora quieres plantar un pedazo teatro
con tu nombre, ahí, bien grande, para que
todos te recuerden por los siglos de los siglos?
¡Claro que sí, guapetón!
¡Aquí llega China con la tarjeta de crédito!
¿Y ahora que, Rajapaksa?
¿Qué quieres un puerto de aguas profundas
en Hambantota para que Sri Lanka se convierta
en el nuevo Singapur?
¡Pues claro que sí, guapetón!
¡Aquí llega China con la tarjeta de crédito!
En otras palabras, Sri Lanka tiene tantísimos
proyectos de lujo ahora mismo, que si sueltan
a TER por ahí, se quedaría a vivir ahí
para el resto de sus días.
Y diréis ¿Pero cuánto ha costado semejante
lujo asiático?
Pues no lo saben ni ellos…
La crisis de la deuda en Sri Lanka es tan
grave que ni siquiera el gobierno sabe cuando
dinero debe
Para que lo entendáis mejor, el año pasado,
el gobierno de Sri Lanka recaudó 14.800 millones
de dólares en impuestos.
Pues bien, de todo ese dinero, 12.300 millones
de dólares se van para pagar las deudas que
tienen, principalmente con China.
Y, aún así, siguen debiendo dinero ¿Y qué
pasa cuando debes dinero a China y no puedes
pagar?
Aquí es cuando viene el problema de tener
un sugar Daddy.
Al principio todo es fantástico: te pagan
esos zapatos de tacón, el caviar, la joyería…
pero luego tienes que dar algo a cambio ¿Y
qué les gusta a los chinos?
Pues esto…
Sri Lanka ofrece formalmente el puerto de
HAMBANTOTA a las empresas chinas en un acuerdo
de 99 años.
Por supuesto, en este contrato de 99 años
está bien clarito que no pueden usar el puerto
para cosas militares.
Pero a ver quien le dice a China lo que puede
o no puede hacer con su propiedad.
Con tantísimas deudas por pagar, Rajapaksa
no puede decirle que no a su sugardaddy.
Y ahora os preguntareis ¿Qué pasará cuando
Rajapaksa abandone el poder?
Pues… ya tenemos una respuesta.
Lo cierto es que, pese a sus esfuerzos de
propaganda y culto a la personalidad, Rajapaksa
perdió las elecciones en 2015.
Sin embargo, el dinero no entiende de propaganda.
Así que, la ideología del nuevo gobierno
importa más bien poco: Sri Lanka está entrempada
con su deuda China.
Pero OK!
Ya sé lo que estáis pensando!
Esto es lo que pasa con Sri Lanka, que es
un país pequeño ¿Qué pasa con los países
más grandes?
Pues vamos a dar un paseo por Pakistan.
El puerto de GWADAR en Pakistan es otro ejemplo
de esto que llamamos la diplomacia del sugardaddy.
Por cierto ¿Por qué no hay ninguna palabra
en español para describir lo que es un sugardaddy?
En fin ¿Habéis oído hablar alguna vez GWADAR
en Pakistan?
Si hombre, Gwadar, famoso en el mundo entero
por… Vale, yo tampoco había oído hablar
de Gwadar en la vida.
Sin embargo, de la noche a la mañana, este
sitio se ha convertido en el un punto importantísimo
para el corredor China-Pakistan: una ruta
comercial donde China se está gastando 62.000
millones de dólares.
Sólo la primera fase de la construcción
de este puerto ha costado alrededor de 200
millones de dólares.
El corredor económico de China-Pakistan es
un eslabón muy importante en la cadena de
la Iniciativa Belt and Road y permitirá la
posibilidad de un ruta de la seda marítima
para el siglo 21. –He Lifeng, presidente
de la Comisión de Desarrollo nacional Chino.
¡Y no sólo hablamos de un puerto!
China se está gastando otros 2000 millones
de dólares en montar una refinería de petróleo
por la zona ¿Tiene sentido económico?
Pues… en este caso, sí.
Un puerto y un gasoducto por ahí vendría
muy bien para conectar Asia con Oriente Medio.
De hecho, Gwadar puede convertirse fácilmente
en un centro logístico de primera.
Así que sí, tiene sentido que China quiera
hacer negocios por ahí.
Pero claro, 2000 millones de dólares también
sirven para hacer que el Gobierno de Pakistan
esté muy contento… y dependa mucho más
de ti.
Si quieren mantener todas esas infraestructuras
de lujo… más les vale tener a su sugardaddy
satisfecho.
Y, por si no os habíais dado cuenta, ya no
se trata de un país pequeño.
Pakistan tiene 200 millones de personas y…
¡Oh sorpresa!
Resulta que son el mayor enemigo de la India.
Pero, ya puestos a hablar de paises grandes,
vamos con otro: Bangladesh.
Bangladesh tiene 164 millones de habitantes.
De hecho, es el país más densamente poblado
del mundo.
Y adivinad quien les vende todo el arsenal
militar que utilizan ¡Exacto!
China.
Y, por supuesto, no solo hablamos de armas.
China también está construyendo un puerto
“de uso no military”.
En total, Bangladesh le debe 8000 millones
de dólares a China.
En otras palabras, que Bangladesh tampoco
está en condiciones de decirle que no a su
sugardaddy.
¡Pero ahora esperad un momento!
Fijaos en este mapa: ¿Qué tienen en común
Bangladesh, Sri Lanka y Pakistan?
Miradlo bien.
Dejad lo que estéis hacienda y mirad el mapa
¿Lo veis?
¡TODOS estos países rodean a la India!
¿Y porque esto son malas noticias para la
India?
Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
ENEMIGO A LAS PUERTAS
Ya lo veis… India está rodeada de puertos
Chinos.
Por supuesto, por el momento, todos estos
puertos no tienen uso military.
Pero podrían tenerlo.
Por ejemplo, en 2017, un submarino Chino quería
atracar en el puerto de Sri Lanka.
El gobierno, que ya no era el de Rajapaksa,
denegó el permiso.
Y pudo hacerlo porque, en principio, el contrato
que tienen dice que el puerto de Hambantota
no es para uso militar.
Pero… todo eso puedo cambiar.
Basta que vayan a renegociar su deuda un día
para que China saque el tema militar.
Pero… ¿Qué significa todo esto para la
India?
Pues… volvamos a nuestras islas favoritas.
Las islas de Andamar y Nicobar donde viven
los salvajes sentineleses.
Como decíamos, por aquí, la India podría
bloquear rutas comerciales.
Y, tal y como está la cosa hoy en día, China
no podría hacer nada en respuesta.
Pero ahora imaginad lo que pasaría si China
tuviera bases militares rodeando a la India.
De repente, China podría enviar tropas a
la India por todos los lados.
Todo esto explica por qué el primer ministro
Indio, Narendra Modi, está tan asustado ¿Y
qué está haciendo?
Pues… una estrategia que va por dos lados.
Por un lado, la vía diplomática.
El Primer Ministro Indio, Narendra Modi, visitará
China para tener un encuentro personal con
Xi Jinping
Pero también hay otra vía.
La que podríamos llamar el “si culo veo,
culo quiero”.
Básicamente, si China está construyendo
su collar de perlas… India está haciendo
lo mismo.
Pero esperad un momento!
China tiene suficiente dinero como para ir
por la vida como un sugardaddy pero… ¿La
India?
Vale, llevan creciendo muchos años pero no
tienen ni punto de comparación con China.
Entonces… si no tienen dinero ¿Qué pueden
hacer?
Pues básicamente, una palabra: DAR MIEDO.
Pensadlo bien… hay un montón de países
preocupados por una posible expansión militar
china.
Y ahí es cuando llega China y dice “mira
la que se está liando por ahí… tenemos
que parar los pies a los Chinos”
Uno de estos países es Francia.
Los franceses están muy preocupados porque
cada día, pierden la influencia que tenían
en África.
Así que, en 2018, el Gobierno de Nueva Delhi
firmó un pacto estratégico con Francia para
abrir bases navales en el Océano Índico.
Eso significa que ahora la India tiene acceso
a los puertos de Francia en Djibouti ¡Pero
aquí no termina la cosa!
India está construyendo su propio collar
de perlas para rivalizar con China en el Océano
Índico.
India esta luchando para asegurar alianzas
mientras China expande su dominio naval en
lo que era la área de influencia tradicional
de la India.
Eso explica que la India ya esté construyendo
una base naval en las SEYCHELLES y que esté
negociando con OMAN para tener acceso a sus
puertos.
¿Y qué significa todo esto?
Pues que la India ya tiene su propio collar
de perlas, que va por Madagascar, Yibuti,
Oman, las Seychelles… hasta Singapur.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque la India
no es el único país que quiere parar a China!
El verano pasado, la presidenta de Taiwan,
TSAI ING WEN dijo que China es una amenaza
para la democracia global.
Y lo mismo pasa con Tailandia, que ya se está
asociando con Europa, Japón y Estados Unidos
para hacer frente a China.
¡No sólo eso!
Si la India quiere competir con China, necesita
un aliado más poderoso.
Y ese no es otro que Japón.
Segunda reunion del foro Indio-Japonés
¿Lo véis ahora?
China está intentando rodear a la India…
y la India esta intentando rodear a China.
En ciencia política, a esta situación la
llamamos DUELO MEXICANO.
Un duelo mexicano es una posición donde dos
países controlan una región y esperan que
el otro haga un movimiento en falso.
Así que ¿Qué podría pasar aquí?
¿Una escalada militar?
Pues básicamente, a no se que lleguen a un
acuerdo, parece que ambos van a seguir gastando
más y más dinero en defensa para evitar
un posible ataque ¿Veis como la política
es divertida?
¡Si es que, os tendríais que suscribir todos
a VisualPolitik!
Porque ahora muchos diréis ¿Y qué está
haciendo Estados Unidos y Europa con todo
esto?
Pues atentos, porque pronto sacaremos otro
vídeo de esta serie sobre el collar de perlas.
En ese vídeo vamos a hablar de tecnología.
Pero, claro, si no os lo queréis perder,
tendréis que suscribiros a este canal y darle
a la campanita para que os lleguen las notificaciones.
Mientas tanto, la pregunta es para vosotros…
¿Veremos como China y la India viven en un
permanente duelo mexicano?
¿Cuánto puede durar esta situación?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo.
Un abrazo y hasta pronto.